so you've done all the legwork now I
promise I'm not going to make you do any
more crunching with numbers or algebra I
just want you to engage visually with
what's going on okay time to go go 40
good good good
okay so Shh eyes up for a second eyes up
if des mots isn't loaded yet it doesn't
matter I just want you to see what's
going on so that when you get to des
Vosges you'll know what to do the first
thing we're gonna work out is how do we
ever get this picture can we confirm
what's going on okay so I'm still
waiting for a few eyes up still waiting
for a few because we're almost all there
don't take this just yet what should I
do it because there's a couple little
tricks over on the right-hand side but
this is just in the way on the right
hand side you can see that gray button
that says functions okay
we're going to talking a lot about
functions later this year but under
functions you can see there's a few
different categories is trig which
stands for geometry their stature stands
for statistics and then the last one
along you can click on this now is misc
for miscellaneous okay go ahead and
click on that you should see the same
menu I do okay now don't click anything
after that I want you to look carefully
we're looking at logs right now on this
little screen if I'm counting them right
there are actually three different logs
we can choose from there's only one I'm
interested in seeing here in the middle
there's one that says L M that's a kind
of log it's an abbreviation worried
about later
this one says log and this one says
logger then it's a little a down the
bottom this last one that's the one I
want you to click can you click on that
one okay
okay now you'll notice up in the top
left-hand corner you've got this little
log thing appears and your cursor should
be at the bottom that cursor belongs to
the base what's our base to so go ahead
put two and then if you use I mean you
can click on it with your with your
cursor but it's a bit awkward for me I'm
going to use these arrows down here
they're a bit more precise I'm just
going to tap once to the right once
again and now I'm inside the brackets
and I've got what inside the brackets X
and automagically is cut out there's the
shape so okay now hold on a second I
need to show you something just bear
with you
okay whoopsie-daisy
whoops okay now um I said I hope you
still get your book there I said you
wouldn't do any more calculations I
wasn't lying
however you do need to pick up your
pencil or pen for a second because I
want to show you something that's very
closely related to this that will
hopefully make everything fall into
place okay so next away you've got all
of your values and what have you what I
want you to remember is for example if I
say 2 to the 5 equals 32 so I'll zoom in
a little bit
do you see that can't read that's a bit
messy but work with me to the 5 equals
32 so this is an equation which has
powers in it and I can rewrite it in
terms of logs how do I rewrite this
thing so it got logs in it tuition drive
shot okay now well done we should have a
look at this have a look at this these
are just saying the same thing you can
even see all the numbers all the same
but it's just looking at from a
different point of view okay if I'm
looking at a house from the inside
rather than the outside
same house different perspective okay
now if that's the case then think about
this because this is what we've all just
drawn and gotten desmos to graph for us
in just the same way that you can
rewrite this exponential as a log I can
write this log as an exponential what
will it be
think think before you speak take a
second look up the symbols what I want
to point out I want us all to figure
this together and you can tell us if you
got the right answer second do you see
for these first two let me divide this
up for these first two you write the
basis of the saved you notice the twos
always
the bottom okay so down here the same
thing will be the case to ^ something
what's the something see how the five
the power up here and then it becomes
the number over there so therefore this
is the number on that side so therefore
this is two power of y equals x ok now
we've grasp things a lot like this in
the past but not quite
we've graph things like this where's my
colors hold on there we go
we have graph stuff like this right
what's the difference between the black
of the red do you see the X to the Y's
or sort of swap places see that so now
I've been here come back to des Vosges
what I want you to write is - if you
look at this AE ^ B button down there
you can get a power out of it and then
go to to the power of X now have a look
at those two together because you've
seen 2 to the X before you graph these
before whether they call it again
certainly not a parabola what is this
guy it's an exponential right now have a
look at this what's going on these are
related aren't they
okay one more thing underneath your two
equations over here I want you to just
type one more thing just type X okay now
if you want pick up your screen pick up
your laptop and just um just rotate it
so this y equals x line is straight up
and down
do you see it can you see that you've
got that symmetry there right yeah lots
of laptops of 45 degrees okay so our log
graph is just a reflected version of
this exponential graph okay
that's their relationship that make
sense yes
okay good now here's all they're going
to finish I'm going to let you have a
play a little bit and then I'm going to
assign the first question of the next
exercise because you don't need any
instruction for it okay
see these graphs here just some get rid
of them for a second just press X and
get rid of them okay so now you've got
this arm log base two of X here
underneath it underneath it I want you
to make a new log equation like so go to
functions log base a and this time C on
the left hand side over here there's an
ABC button you can access just a noble
QWERTY keyboard and just type in a okay
once you've done that Chuck you the X
and if you've done it like I have see
how I've got an A there in annex a it
says add a slider yeah Kevin's got the
blue add slide I'm good okay click it go
ahead and cook it okay now mine
currently looks like this my currently
looks like this what I want you to do is
just eyes up for a second
eyes up and then I'm gonna let you play
yourself okay take this slider and move
it take the fighter remove it what's
going on as you move it back and forth
what are you getting good I've had it
Alan said it which is appropriate to
Ellen's one of the logs yeah you'll
understand that joke later on even more
so as I pointed out we're changing the
base and as you change the base do you
notice the shape kind of flexes around a
little bit for example if I go log base
3 yes you're right well
have a look at this guy's the Greek my
green one is log base three and my
purple one is log base two how would you
describe the difference when the base
gets bigger you get this green graph how
would you describe it it's tricky to
describe you right you can't simply say
you remember with parabolas doing for
others we made them squishy and fat no
like a fee right it's sort of happening
but not really because look this parts
getting lower
but this part's getting higher do you
notice that sort of stretch and as you
make a even bigger it gets even more
exaggerated look at this here you go see
that so this guy sort of hugs the
asymptotes even closer and this one get
even lower does that make sense